my name is Aisha comedy for the embassy
or asset management group Lagos Nigeria
I'm a nice to think about empowerment of
a woman a grassroot level teach them
about their basic rights and there were
I think that's one thing that we should
be able to achieve in this one year
won't change I think it's very important
that the African woman you know who
everybody in the content has described
as been the backbone of development and
on the continent should now be able to
first base in this new growth this new
development is near Africa that we're
looking at and the only way they can do
that successfully is this we give them
which some are there being played for
more importantly about their wealth what
is it what is this that they can
contribute either that they can bring
about positive change however they can
demand more of their leaders and high is
that they themselves can be part of this
process and they have to be able to
engage the process as well as be able to
engage in the process